Okay.
So let's begin.
I asked you to,
to bear two questions in
mind in reading the Eichmann.
MMM.
And I'm going to get to those in a minute,
but before we get to that,
who, who was ad off? Eichmann
okay.
Who was that? Oh, fuck man.
Wow.
You're going to have to
get, get a, a microphone.
Okay.
He was the expert on Jewish
immigration and relocation,
but why was his job, what was he, what
was his Chinese, what was he there to do?
Um Hm.
Well,
in the beginning he was sent to talk
to the Jewish elder council and try to
negotiate,
um,
the moving of thousands of Jewish people
as quickly as possible from different
areas
throughout Europe. Correct.
What else was he supposed to do?
Why don't you give somebody
else a chance that,
that was certainly part of what he was
doing. What else was he supposed to do?
What's he,
was he somebody,
was he somebody who was involved in
designing the final solution as it was
called in? The third way
was, was he a policymaker?
April is shaking their heads. No, he
wasn't. He was basically an implementer,
right?
He was,
he was obeying orders and his job
was to make the trains run on time,
literally speaking their
trains that were going to, um,
take Jews to concentration camps or was
it complicated logistical feat and he
was in charge of it. His
job was to make sure, uh,
that it was an efficiently run operation.
Um,
as I said at the end of the war, he was
actually captured by the allied forces,
but they didn't realize what
a significant figure he was.
He was subsequently released,
inadvertently made his way to Latin
America where he lived on the cover until
the Mossad found out where he was.
And then in 1960,
they kidnapped him,
brought him to Israel where he was tried.
In the trial that you read about
in this book, uh, for debt today,
found guilty of crimes are grants to
the Jewish people and crimes against
humanity and put to death.
MMM,
okay.
What kind of a person was he?
What do you think motivated him
when you read, you read this,
what kind of a person? What's,
what stood out about him? Anybody?
Okay.
It seemed throughout the,
uh,
throughout the text that he was driven
by this idea of self advancement.
The need for,
uh,
he wanted to, he wanted
to get ahead. Yeah.
He wanted to impress his superiors.
Yeah. First and foremost,
I believe he wanted to get
an a right. Pretty much, yes.
What he was that, that's one thing
that strikes you about him. Yeah.
What else struck you about him?
Uh, the thoughtlessness that
he demonstrated throughout
the camp. They what? Sorry.
Thoughtlessness just kind of the
blind obedience to the first word.
If he wants to be moist, not
our reflective man. Not at all.
It's not somebody who would
question authority. Right.
Did you get the impression
he hated Jews? No. No.
What makes you say that?
Uh, I mean, full first during
his testimony, he claimed
that he didn't hate Jews.
Uh, he actually was a supporter of
the Zionist movement, uh, through the,
some of the readings that
he did before 1939. And,
uh,
throughout even the years between 1939,
1945,
when he was carrying out all these actions
that were detrimental to the Jewish
people, he found himself
having Jewish friends,
working with the Jewish people,
trying to find solutions.
But as long as that didn't contradict
the orders of his superiors,
I think you've got him exactly right.
He's not somebody who was not somebody
motivated by a restoral antisemitism.
Indeed. You get the impression
reading this book that if,
if his superiors had said to him,
instead of shipping people to
concentration camps, we want you to ship,
um, munitions around the third
way to resupply the army.
All we want you to ship, um, car parts.
He would have done it with the same,
um,
zeal and desire to improve his,
uh,
standing with his superiors. He wouldn't
have been any different about it.
Um, he didn't seem to
be like a, somebody who,
who saw this as a great opportunity
to do something he really believed in.
He was simply trying to
get an a China get ahead,
trying to impress his superiors,
do it good and efficient job at
whatever it was that he was asked to do.
Um,
is that if that, if that's an
accurate description about him,
it's quite chilling.
Right.
And I think this brings
us to the first question.
What is it that makes you
uncomfortable about this
man?
One of the things I
asked you to think about,
what makes you uncomfortable
about Eichmann?
Yeah.
The fact that he was just, um, basically
not thinking about what he was doing.
So someone else had total control
of what he was going to do.
So he has his own reflectiveness
is what makes you uncomfortable.
Right. Cause that means really
anyone can be like that.
It kind of makes you reflect on
yourself and not just on human nature.
Okay. So you, you feel he should
have been questioning the, the, uh,
the authorities that were giving him the
orders to do this? Yeah, that'd be nice.
Okay. That's definitely one thing that
makes people uncomfortable. What else?
Anybody else?
Yeah.
Um, it was just that his on reflectiveness
transferred to the fact that,
uh, well, you know, he
wanted to do his job well,
but the fact was that he wasn't
just transporting munitions.
These were people's lives.
Uh,
supposedly people he easily
could have been friends with.
Right. He Wa he wasn't thinking about
the larger purpose. Um, so it's,
it's connected to the on reflectiveness,
although we'll see that one of the themes
in this course that political theorist
write about is the whole idea of detaching
means from ends of thinking about how
to do things efficiently without
reference to what it is that we are doing.
But it makes us uncomfortable. What else
makes you uncomfortable about this man?
What makes you, what makes your
skin crawl when you think about him?
Anything else? Yeah,
let's get the microphone.
He was gloating like when he was in
Argentina and he was doing his interviews,
he was gloating about the millions of
people that had died because of him,
because of his work.
He was pleased that he
had done a good job. Yeah.
It wasn't as if he was doing this
with any sense of reluctance. Right.
He was doing it with even,
even though you don't get the sense that
this man had a visceral antisemitism
about him,
he certainly was pleased with the fact
that his superiors like what he was doing
and that,
uh,
he was being commended for it and he was,
um,
uh,
getting ahead.
Anything, anything else that
makes you uncomfortable about him?
Yeah,
he brings up the term
idealist and he sort of, um,
attaches a sense of honor and loyalty
to the Third Reich that we find
uncomfortable
because of what it's trying to call to,
to his superiors that he thought it
was important to a by his superiors.
Okay. Uh, anybody at somebody over there?
I was going to say, yeah, over there.
Um, well it's not something
specific about his actions,
but I'm uncomfortable
with the fact that one,
he is constantly normal by
all the tests. And two, he,
when he wasn't thinking at
all, he actually saw, he was
thinking and he filled it.
All the people when you get into
thinking that he's smart and competent,
so it makes you wonder if that's
the stupidity is just something,
was he all of us?
Yup.
I think that's right as well.
So here you have a man who is completely
unreflective about what he's doing.
He's a bang orders from above.
He's not breaking the law right at
all into implementing the law as it,
as it's enacted in the Third Reich.
And he's going about something that is
absolutely monstrous with calm efficiency
and good humor, uh, and going home. Uh,
you could imagine this guy going home
at the end of the week playing with
children, uh, being
friends with the neighbors,
going to a barbecue and going back to
work the next day. All right. It's, uh,
one of our ranch raises to capture this.
Is that one of the things that seems so
chilling about this guys that he doesn't
seem like a monster.
He seems like the man next door and the,
and this, the phrase she uses is the
banality of evil. He doesn't seem like,
uh,
um,
okay.
Somebody who's got some,
uh,
unusual trait. So it, I think, you know,
to push to turn the screw
a little bit further,
one of the things that makes people
uncomfortable with a man like this is sort
of makes you wonder how would you
have behaved in his situation?
You know, you hope you would
have not behaved as he did,
but he doesn't seem that unusual.
He seems completely unremarkable,
man. Fairly typical a
guy, uh, doing what he's,
you know, putting one foot in
front of the other, in, in,
in the situation in which he finds
himself and getting on with his life.
Um, and that I think is
captured by her phrase,
the banality of evil. Um, okay.
Let's now just put Eifman to one side
for a minute and think about the second
question I asked you to reflect
upon while reading this.
What two things make you most
uncomfortable about around,
about the events surrounding Eichmann's
apprehension, trial and execution.
First of all, this, why
did Israel do what it did?
Why do you think they
went and came dot him?
Okay.
Mean the normal process,
you know, if, if you,
mmm.
If you're trying to get hold of a
criminal and in other countries you,
you go and you apply for
extradition and he'd come the,
you make the case and you go to court
and the person is arrested and, and uh,
eventually they brought
that brought to trial.
MMM.
So why didn't they do that?
Why did they do what they did?
Anybody either no one to take a guess.
Why did they do that?
Anyone want to try that?
Yeah.
Well,
it seems to imply that they might have
been concerned or might've suspected
other countries wouldn't be sympathetic
to their wish to try it. Okay.
They might have worried that he'd
Garner a certain amount of international
support or,
or defense,
sorry, I'm sorry guys living
in. I think that's right.
If they tried to extradite him, it,
it wouldn't have worked as soon as he,
he knew there were many other former
Nazis in Argentina and elsewhere in Latin
America. Uh, the minute
he realized that they,
they knew where he was and who he was,
he would have gone on to
ground and vanished. And, uh,
they would have been so much sand in
the we all stuff the extradition system
that uh,
they made a judgment,
which is probably a valid judgment that
if they were going to get them at all,
this was the way they
were going to get him.
MMM.
So that's why they did it pretty much.
That's why they did it.
MMM.
Okay. So given that, that's
why they did it, what,
if anything makes you uncomfortable
about what, what they did
over here?
We need to mine.
Yeah.
In one of the last two chapters,
I believe they're discussing the reasons
for judgment against him in on all the
accounts.
And one of them will,
she's discussing the four main points
that they attempt to prove through the
prosecution and Indian in some of them
they discuss the term in Doobie au
contraire rule on, which is I guess
when in doubt act against the defendant.
And that was kind of just when we don't
have necessarily all of the evidence
because a lot of it is speculative,
we will act in a way that will,
okay. So there, there was not a lot
of attention to the rules of evidence.
Yeah. Right. Okay. So that's one thing
that there were a lot of what it,
what we would think of as procedural
irregularities and this trial.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
I was uncomfortable with the speed
of the execution. It happened, uh,
extremely soon after his appeal and
plea for mercy within a couple hours.
Right. He was, it was, it was the way
expectations at done in China today,
not the way executions at done in the
United States today. Right. He was,
it was very rapid. And why, why
were you uncomfortable with that?
I think there's no doubt that what he did
was wrong, but you at least have to, uh,
go through the procedures just to ensure
that justice is actually served so that
even if it was correct that
they should have, you know,
that he deserved the death
penalty. Um, I think the actual,
the protocol should have
been followed in that, um,
he should have gotten his time
to make the appeal and, uh,
okay.
Anything else?
Make anybody uncomfortable about
what was done over. Yeah. Yeah.
Um, it mentioned in the beginning
how shall we, the trial was, and, um,
one part that I thought really stuck with
me was when the author mentioned that,
uh, Israel, Israel's
laws itself prohibitive.
Josh is Israeli law prohibited
Jewish and non Jewish marriage.
So how the two societies, although
one is certainly worse than the other,
I think on a moral level there's
still no perfect society.
And that really kind of
was disturbing I think.
Okay. So it was something of
a show trial. Yeah, it was,
there was more than one
agenda here I want agenda was,
uh, justice bringing him to justice,
but clearly there was an agenda,
revenge and there was an agenda
of catharsis for many of the,
the,
um,
people who testified who came there,
it was very important for them personally
to get up and speak about what had
happened to them for which
he was held responsible.
So there were multiple
agendas going on here,
only one of which was what
we normally think office,
what's going on in a criminal prosecution.
Anything else?
Make anybody uncomfortable?
Yeah. Over here.
Um, the author had mentioned that Israel
wouldn't have gone to the trouble of
kidnapping him if he wasn't
automatically going to be found guilty.
Like they weren't, it was just a
foregone conclusion from the beginning.
And that's just really sending
such a bad precedent for, you know,
trials in general. Um, so even
though it was clear he was guilty,
the fact that it was just,
you know,
they wouldn't have even trouble troubled
going through it if they thought there
was any possibility of
him being found innocent.
Oh, nice. So it was, it was, uh, the
outcome was never in doubt. Hmm. Okay.
And that makes you nervous because,
hang on.
Okay.
Um, because while his cases
is pretty black and white,
that's just setting a precedent
for the future. And if,
if in a case where it's so clearly,
um, he's so clearly guilty,
you can't use real evidence and you can't
actually go through the steps with a
meaningful steps of a trial to
find him guilty, then it's hard.
Then it seems like in the future,
other trials where it's not a black and
white maybe made more into show trials
as well.
Like if he could clearly have been found
guilty in a meaningful way with real
evidence and they just kind
of didn't try to do that.
Okay. Anything else? Make anyone
uncomfortable? Yeah. Over here
also the lack of evidence
that was eligible for
procurement on this side of the
defense and the lack of defense
support really stuck out to me.
It didn't have what we call discovery.
There was a lot of procedural
irregularities here.
They didn't have access to the
evidence, uh, and they, they could make,
there were a lot of what, you know,
when you all go off to the Lord,
the Lord is calling you
learn criminal procedure.
A few years from now there was a lot of
what would be called reversible error in
this trial that is on an on appeal
would have run into trouble procedural
problems. And so there were procedural
problems in the trial. What else?
Over there?
Yeah.
Um, it makes me uncomfortable that Israel
was even claiming jurisdiction in the
case.
Considering the crime did not happen on
Israeli soil and that they literally had
to send their secret service to kidnap
him to bring him to Israeli soil.
Okay.
So you're,
you are travel that they thought
they had jurisdiction in this matter,
right, because the crime
didn't happen on Israeli soil.
Any other reason why one might be
troubled that they claimed jurisdiction?
Um,
it felt like it was the country
kind of speaking for, uh,
people are speaking for humanity in
a way that was just unsettling to me.
Okay.
Did they arrogated to themselves the
right to prosecute in the name of the
Jewish people and in the name of humanity,
crimes against humanity,
they convicted him, uh, of you might say,
who appointed them to do
that? Uh, I think, uh,
there's a lot of, uh, a lot of truth
to what you say there, but this,
there are a number of other
aspects to it as well.
Why else might we be troubled that they
thought they had jurisdiction to do this?
What does jurisdiction mean anyway?
What does jurisdiction?
Yeah.
Um, I think it's equally troubling that
they thought that they had to do this.
I mean they talked a lot about the way
that former Nazis are being tried in
Germany and how lenient
their punishments were.
I think that that is kind of the
need of the German people to kind of,
I don't know, kind of like twist
history in that way to kind of blame
away from these people who
obviously did a lot of things wrong
in a way force Israel to have to kind
of take this berry like drastic sort of
extra legal action.
Okay.
But so I think you all make a now a number
of valid points, but somebody wants,
say, devil's advocate
would say, well look,
nobody's seriously alleging that he was
incorrectly convicted nobody seriously
alleging that he didn't do this.
Uh,
we've already said by assumption
if that they were working on the,
on the premise that if,
if they did and did,
if they didn't prosecute him,
he wasn't going to happen at all.
Um, so what's that? It
be that troubled about
is there,
is there a counterargument to that?
Yeah.
Over there.
Next time it might not be so clear.
Another country might use this
as a place for themselves.
Press it. An issue that, um, and what
are the precedents were worried about?
Okay.
Um,
the precedent of claiming jurisdiction
over any number of crimes that occur
elsewhere.
The precedent of basically kidnapping
in order to have a legal system,
the precedent of show trials
for serious, you know, it,
it potentially a huge issue.
I don't know if you noticed,
um, uh, um,
Israeli politician Livni
when cans for the trip,
you're Britain a few weeks ago
because they discovered that,
uh,
some prosecutor in Britain was going
to have her arrested for war crimes in
Gaza.
She had been foreign minister during
the Gaza invasion and a year ago and the
British government was very embarrassed
and I tried to fix it so that that
couldn't be done again. But you know, um,
piano shag couldn't travel to many places
because he was eventually going to be
arrested. Um, there are, now,
there are some countries in which
their conversations about, uh,
whether they might try and arrest Donald
Rumsfeld if he travels to, to them.
Um, for, you know, what
went on at Abu Ghraib.
So if a, if countries starts
setting themselves up and saying,
we have the right to
prosecute war criminals,
mmm.
You know who, who's gotten,
how's it going to be regulated,
who they're going to be answerable to
that. So that, those sorts of, if my,
it might look okay in this case because
mmm,
we're not, you know, we,
nobody seriously contends that Eifman
and do these things or that they were
legitimate, the justifiable. Uh,
but this is precedent setting issue,
uh, that you have to worry about it. Um,
anything else? Anything I haven't
mentioned that you might find troubling?
I mean, my, my, somebody not outside luck.
This guy is big.
It's not,
it's not just that it
Washington on Israeli soil.
This guy has big prosecuted
by a legal system,
which they didn't even exist when he quit,
when he committed his,
his crimes. And
furthermore, he was a bang,
a legal system that did
exist, right? He was,
he was in Germany in the 1940s that bang,
uh,
the laws of the third way.
He wasn't breaking any laws then.
Um,
and now he's being tried in a legal system
and a country that didn't even exist
then, um, for violating other laws.
Isn't this isn't,
isn't this just victus justice?
Okay.
So why don't we say about that was,
was it, did they go the wrong thing?
A lot of people I think would,
would grant until much of that of what's
been said here and still be troubled by
the notion that they
shouldn't have done it because
you would never be brought to justice.
Okay.
Now let's take a step back from this
conversation and bring in what we were
doing in the first half of our discussion.
Don't you think there's a tension now
between the two halves of our discussion?
Because when we were talking about what
made us uncomfortable about Eichmann,
it was his,
his abdicating his moral responsibility
to question the prevailing law,
to question
the legitimacy of what
he was being asked to do.
His odd and reflectiveness,
uh,
his lack of interest in the
overall goals of the enterprise.
That he was part of this completely
unreflective person doing what he was told
to do, a bang orders, trying to
produce his superiors and get ahead.
That's what made us sign comfortable.
But now when we talk about
what Israel did in 1960,
it seems like, uh, what makes
you uncomfortable there is,
um, the fact that they did do all
of those things. They did say,
they sat down and they said, well, yeah,
there's international Lauren this
extradition, but hey, you know what,
it's not going to happen. Uh, and if, if,
if we want to get the
morally correct outcome here,
we have to take it upon ourselves not to
accept the existing rules of the game,
not to accept the existing order,
but to stand up for what's right.
Okay.
So how is it that we,
on the one hand,
are uncomfortable with Ironman
for failing to do that,
but here we're uncomfortable when,
when these Israeli,
um,
okay,
commandos and prosecutors do exactly that.
Is that a real contradiction
or is am I missing something?
Anybody want to pick up that?
What do you think?
So I, I do think it's a contradiction
in very worth examining,
but one sort of interesting aspect of
it is just that I think part of what we
object to about the trial is that it
claimed to be following a certain legal
order.
Um,
and that it sort of associated this
working outside the system with a cyst.
What is that legal with, with
these Israeli legal system? Um,
I mean with, with the judicial
court system of the nation.
But didn't, you know, even that
even, I mean, I, I take your point,
but it's not very plausible. It's not
the best defense because after all, uh,
you know,
as it's come up in this conversation,
even by the standards of exist against
regular law, this was not a great,
right. What I'm saying is it, is it
this, this trial, which clearly wasn't,
which clearly, you know, broke a
lot of what we would consider the,
the good standards for trial sort of
tainted somehow the idea of the Israeli
judicial system. I mean,
it seems like maybe,
I'm not saying this
would have been better,
but some of our objections wouldn't
necessarily apply if it had been really
obviously just like a
political assassination because
they didn't know what else
to do with him. I mean, not
that that would be acceptable
either necessarily, but,
um, there's just the relation
to this to the courts. Okay.
It's in there somehow too.
Okay.
Okay. So that might speak
to part of it, but any,
anything else about this tension between,
on the one hand we are worried that,
that I advocated his moral autonomy
and responsibility on the other hand,
uh, where I'm comfortable that
they asserted their ass. Yeah.
Well,
I'm not really quite sure the tension
I'm completely exists if we're to assume
that one system of government
or one system of laws is
like legitimate and valid,
um,
like the Israeli trial system,
like having a system that
lets you have appeals that,
um, doesn't, um, kidnap people illegally,
um, versus a system kills
millions of people, um,
who are innocent of doing anything wrong,
um,
and kills him simply for who they are.
Um,
so Eichmann's case,
it seems to me that it is legitimate to
challenge him to challenge the system
and to um,
be shocked or disappointed when he
doesn't then just goes along with it. Um,
on the other hand, to bring
someone like that to justice, um,
it is a bit troubling that, um, when
you have a system that does work, um,
or that we widely believed to
be a system that, um, like a,
a judicial system that does work and
is sort of widely accepted to be a good
system.
Um,
setting a precedent there could
be potentially a bad thing.
I'm not quite sure there's attention if
in one case challenging the system is
good and the other may be challenging.
The system has more of
a gray area of issues.
Well, I think you've hit the nail
on the head. I think that, uh,
the pension goes away if we say, well, uh,
you know,
the reason we are troubled by Eichmann's
failure to ask any questions about the,
the,
what he was being asked to do within the
legal order of the Third Reich is that
it was an illegitimate legal
order. It was, uh, as, uh,
RN says somewhere in that
was a criminal regime. Um,
and it was his failure to recognize
that that makes us uncomfortable.
On the other hand, when we start talking
about the system of international law,
um,
it has its imperfections,
but we're much more ambivalent about
saying people can ignore it with impunity
because we don't see it as an illegitimate
order in the same way that we did.
Um, so I think you're exactly right.
When you, when you point out that,
that the apparent, this is not a real
tension, it's an apparent tension,
which depends for appearing to
be attention on the fact that we,
most of us don't have any qualms in
thinking about the third wife has an
illegitimate regime.
Uh,
and that that's why we're
uncomfortable with his actions.
Whereas a, when you do have
at least a Fred's lane, uh,
legitimate international legal order,
uh,
we become uncomfortable with people who
flout that. So I think that's right.
But it places the central question of
this course into sharp relief because our
question is, well, what is it that makes
it a regime legitimate or illegitimate?
You know,
if we say you have an ob an an obligation
to resist an illegitimate regime and
to obey and legitimate one,
uh,
that just pushes the question
one step further back,
what is it that makes her
regime legitimate? And, um,
that is the question that we're going to,
uh,
organize our discussion in the,
in the coming weeks and months.
We're basically going to explore five
answers to that question or five types of
answers are five classes of
answers to that question.
And they represent the main ways in which
political legitimacy has been thought
about in the western tradition over
the past several hundred years.
Um,
the first one that we're going to look
at is the utilitarian tradition and the
utilitarian tradition, which we are
going to trace back to Jeremy Bentham.
Um,
we'll start talking about on Friday,
says that a regime is legitimate to the
extent that it maximizes the greatest
happiness of the greatest
number of its citizens.
Now,
there's huge arguments within the
utilitarian tradition as to what counts as
happiness,
how you measure it,
what you do if promoting the happiness
of SOM comes at the expense of the
happiness of others.
Um,
all of those things get argued about
endlessly in the utilitarian tradition.
And we will explore some of
those arguments as we go along.
But the basic idea is that good regimes,
legitimate regimes,
maximize the utility or the happiness
of people who are subject to them.
And then the second
set of answers,
the second tradition we're going to
look at is the Marxist tradition,
which comes into its
own in the 19th century.
And that basically identifies
the legitimacy of the
state with the presence or
absence of exploitation.
Legitimate governments are those
that try to prevent exploitation and
illegitimate governments or those
that facilitate exploitation.
Again,
just as in the utilitarian tradition,
there are huge disagreements about how
to identify utility and measure it in the
Marxian tradition from the beginning.
Uh,
there've been huge disagreement
about what constitutes exploitation,
how you would note when you see it,
what would be involved in eradicating it
and how governments might or might not
be able to do that. Um,
but at the end of the day,
it is the presence of exploitation that
is the marker of an illegitimate order
and it's the possibility of escaping,
um,
exploitation that creates the
possibility of a legitimate order.
And so the Marxian answer to
the question of legitimate,
the legitimacy revolves around
this idea of exploitation.
The third tradition
we've got to look at is,
is what's commonly known as the social
contract tradition and the social
contract tradition founds the legitimacy
of a political order in the notion of
consent agreement.
Again,
you'll find just us with
all these other traditions,
a lot of disagreement about
what constitutes agreement,
what constitutes consent?
Is it some people who actually
agreed at some point in the past
that should bind us? You know, the,
the American founders agreed on certain
things and therefore we should be bound
by what they were agreed upon or is it
what any rational person would agree to?
Is it a hypothetical idea of consent?
Um,
does the consent have to be active?
Do people actually have to engage
in consent or can it be tacit?
Can you demonstrate your
consent simply by not leaving?
All of these issues will get,
um,
a lot of attention when we look
at the social contract tradition,
but in all up for all of their
internal differences and disagreements,
this social contract tradition comes down
to the proposition that the legitimacy
of the state is rooted in
the consent of the governed.
The fourth tradition
we're going to consider
is what I call and the syllabus and the
Anti Enlightenment tradition reacting
against those first three enlightenment
traditions and the anti enlightened
tradition appeals to tradition. Um,
it, it's the tradition tradition.
Um,
the legitimacy of this state
resides and is discovered in
the inherited norms,
practices and traditions off a society.
Again,
we will find people struggling with
and arguing over what constitutes the
tradition, how you all know a
tradition when you trip over it.
What happens when people disagree
about what the tradition implies.
Um,
all those questions are on the table
once we start appealing to tradition.
But, um, at the end of the day, it is,
it is the appeal to tradition itself
that becomes important that when you
criticize the government,
you have to um,
yeah,
appeal to something that's
imminent in an accepted,
in the tradition. Um, the
rights of Englishman, let's say,
um,
as it was appeal to in the 18th century.
Um,
and then there's a tradition about what
the rights of Englishman of thought to
the beam going all the way
back to Magna Carta. Um,
that becomes the basis for arguing about
the legitimacy of the price and actions
of the government.
The faith tradition we're going to look
at is the democratic tradition and the
democratic tradition says that
the legitimacy of the state depends upon
the extent to which it abays something
which we'll call the principle
of affected interests.
That is whether those people
whose interests are affected
by its actions get to
control what it does
cause cousin enough consent you might say.
And indeed the democratic tradition is
a close cousin of the social contract
tradition. But at the end of the
day it's a different tradition. Um,
and often works through but not
always the idea of majority rule.
And the, so the, again,
in the democratic tradition there
are huge controversies about how we
operationalize and apply this idea of
affected anxious is the basis of politics.
Um,
but the,
the underlying notion is that if you
couldn't resolve those issues trying to
make the government,
the um,
agent of people who are affected by
what it does is the name of the game in
promoting legitimacy and undermining
illegitimacy of the steak.
So those are the,
those are the five traditions.
We're going to explore them and we're
going to come back again and again,
not only to the Eichmann problem,
but to
are there practical examples that throw
this question of the legitimacy of the
state into sharp relief.
But at the end of the day,
we are always trying to understand
what the basis for political legitimacy
actually is.
Okay.
We have a couple of
minutes for questions if,
okay.
Anyone would like to,
yeah,
it's Mike over here.
Oh,
what about the notion that might makes
right and at the most powerful stays the
most legitimate.
Okay. Says what about the
notion that might makes, right.
And it's the most powerful states that
get the deed to dictate what legitimacy
is. I mean, you could say that after
all, you know, when, if you think,
think about the example
we've been considering today,
at the end of the Second World War,
um,
we had the Nuremberg trials run by,
you know,
an American Supreme Court justice.
They went to Germany.
They did a lot of what Israel
did in 1960. Actually, you know,
they tried these Germans by,
uh,
laws hadn't existed at the time for
obeying the laws that had existed at that
time. Many of them were executed. Many
of them were in prison. You could say,
this is just, this is just,
um, might, makes, right.
If somebody else had won the war, there
would have been a different outcome. Um,
so this is a, this is a doctrine
which we will consider in the,
in the course of our discussion
actually of utilitarianism. Um,
it is for those of you who want the
jargon that the doctrine of legal
positivism,
anyone want to take a crack at
what legal positivism means?
Anybody know?
No reason you should know
legal positivism was
the doctrine that said,
okay,
exactly what this gentleman
here has been saying,
that
what makes something law is the bell.
The ability to get people to obey.
Yeah.
You know,
if you go back into medieval Europe,
we'll find the distinction between
natural law and positive law.
Natural law is sometimes I
identified with the will of God,
sometimes with timeless
universal moral principles,
some higher law by reference to which we
judge what actual legal systems go are
doing.
So when we say the Third Reich was a
criminal regime and illegitimate regime
where ultimately appealing
to some kind of higher laws,
some natural law idea as to what
constitutes a legitimate regime.
Right? And we're going to talk a
lot more about natural law later.
Well,
legal positivism was the doctrine that
there is no such thing as natural law.
Jeremy Bentham who are going to start
talking about on Friday says natural law,
natural rights. It's dangerous
nonsense, nonsense on stilts.
There's no such thing as natural law
and he is considered as the one of the,
um,
intellectual sources for this
doctrine of legal positivism,
which comes into its own in the
19 century. They're just there.
If you know, you, if you say,
well, there is no higher law,
then the question is,
well then why didn't,
what is law based on one and say is power?
Bentham wanted to say it
should be based on science.
As I mentioned to you last time,
the enlightenment is all
about faith in science. Um,
so we,
we will,
we will consider a version of that
argument when we come to talk about
utilitarianism. Um, but it's a,
it's a good point to make,
particularly in this,
the context of the Eichmann problem.
Now what we're gonna,
what we're gonna do.
I realize now,
I misspoke when I said we're going to
talk about Bentham on fire. I didn't,
I didn't, why didn't some
astute person say, no,
you're not.
We're actually going to talk about lock.
Now you might say,
well why are you going to talk about loc?
And the answer is that lock actually
performs two different functions in this
course, um, that you
will see they, they, uh,
they come together, uh, later on.
You'll see how they come
together later in the course.
But a lock on the one hand we are using
as somebody to provide us with a way of
understanding the enlightenment.
Yeah.
Move in politics.
And as I sent you,
the enlightenment move involves a twin
commitment to the ideas of science as the
basis for social organization and
freedom as the highest good.
And that that enlightenment pair of
assumptions is going to inform the first
three traditions we look at,
right? The utilitarian tradition,
the Marxian tradition and
the social contract tradition
lock will also be looked
at later as a representative of
the social contract tradition.
But what are we going to do in Friday's
lecture is think about the broad themes
of the enlightenment for which,
uh,
the lock reading it is there
and what, and, and it's,
it's going to provide the background
and we will not actually get to
utilitarianism until next Wednesday.
One thing I would say to
you about the lock, uh,
going in on the one hand, and you know,
it's a tremendously famous buckets being
in print continuously for more than 300
years, it's been translated into
all the world's languages. Um,
all the world's major languages and
many of the world's mine languages,
um, locks most important
political writing for sure.
Okay.
Uh, it's not a fast weed. It's not, um,
it's a political pamphlet. It, you know,
it was written for a very particular
political purpose that I'll tell you
something about,
but it's,
it's not a fast we'd in the sense
that what you read for today,
it's a fast read and some of
it's gonna go right by you.
And that's okay. Um, because you might,
you might think, well, not
only is it not a fast read,
but he's going to do a lot
of this in one lecture. Uh,
it seems like a lot to do in 15 minutes,
but the truth is we're going to come
back to lock again and again through this
course and you,
what you're going to discover is that
the ghost of Locke is hovering behind us,
uh, all the way through. Um, in many ways,
modern democratic theory is a footnote
to lock a, and you'll, so you'll see,
we will consider lock as a father of
the enlightenment as a representative of
the social contract tradition. And then
lockin considerations will come in,
uh, to the Marxist tradition,
to the democratic tradition, uh,
to the social contract
tradition, uh, as well. So,
um,
some of what you read for Friday,
we'll go by you don't worry about it
because we're going to revisit lock again
and again and again, uh, as
we go through the course.
Okay?
So we will see you on Friday.
And then that's when we'll
begin talking about John Law.